hello everyone and welcome to the oven
carmichael show-- i am your host Evan
Carmichael I believe in entrepreneur I
believe in you I believe that you can
change the world and I'd like to help
you do it today is an exciting show
today is one of the most important shows
that I've ever done on radio and I'm
excited the topics today one how to get
inspired with your company to thanking
the people who have helped you three
marketing this one is so important the
biggest mistake that most entrepreneurs
make with marketing how you can avoid it
and then for bringing on a team without
sucking up and wasting your time I have
my frappuccino in hand and I'm ready to
get started you need to get inspired for
anybody who's listened to my show ever
you know that I believe that you have to
be passionate about your business if you
are not excited about your business if
you are not spending from a deep passion
you won't achieve success period so i'm
going to assume we've already done that
if you're not passionate close at their
own start something else because you'll
permit it's important but even if you
are super passionate about your business
you still can have trouble getting
inspired it's hard right it's hard
getting up every day and going to work
and do your thing and there are some
days you're on top of the world and
other days we are you're right at the
bottom and as entrepreneurs we have the
ability to create an environment that
inspires us so you want to do that for
your company you want to give yourself
the inspiration on a daily basis to help
you get up and do what you do I recently
went to go watch the movie job it's the
profile of Steve Jobs how he got started
I saw it twice the two different friends
and both times i left the movie feeling
empowered inspired ready for action and
i learned some new things from that that
i put to use in my business and i do
this on a regular basis I surround
myself with things that inspire me
people activity
event that lift me up and inspire me
instead of bringing me down and you have
the opportunity to do the same thing for
your business you're not working at some
nine to five job where you are forced to
work for a boss you hate or forced to
work with coworkers or forth to work on
projects that you don't want to work on
you can't pick everything so make the
choice and make it powerful and choose
things that build you up think about
some of the things in your life think
about the things that your offer think
about the people that you surround
yourself with think about the events
that you go to and the things that you
watch do they build you up do they
inspire you do they give you new ideas
of hope and energy do they take you down
I stopped watching the nightly news
because it's all negative there's
nothing positive that there's no
inspiration there for me I stopped
reading the newspaper same thing it's
all negative news I stopped hanging
around people who didn't believe in what
I was doing and you can make the same
path choices think about three things in
your life that you can change three
habits three things that you're doing
that do not support you and think of
ways to replace them with more powerful
more supportive more uplifting more
inspirational habits so for example
instead of watching the nightly news
maybe you turn on an inspirational movie
like steve jobs instead of reading the
newspaper maybe you pick up a famous
entrepreneur biography of someone who
you respect and look up to and learn
from them instead of hanging around with
people who think your idea is crap and
keep putting you down hanging around the
people who build you up give you ideas
and lift you you have a unique
opportunity here to create an
environment that inspires you make that
choice powerfully think about the people
that you hang out with okay if you have
a toxic environment if you're hanging
out with toxic people you're reading
toxic information you're surrounded by
toxic things how can you expect the
build and amazed
business it's not going to happen and
even if you love what you do and you
have an immense passion for your
business it's still going to be hard to
get up every day and go to work and do
it will make that choice powerfully in
create an environment that supports you
every day giving you ideas and
motivation to help you grow your
business i created my youtube channel
and right now we're doing two videos a
day i created that as a tool to help
uplift entrepreneurs there's not enough
positive information out there and not
just strategies the strategies help you
need to have the strategies to grow your
business but you also need the
motivational booth need that inspiration
so find a habit every day to help
support what you're doing it's so
paramount if you surround yourself with
toxic people talk two things in a toxic
environment you're not going to have
success if you replace those habits the
things that are more empowering and more
inspirational give yourself a much
better at achieving the success that
you're after so I'm going to get to the
question we have Nikki on the line
Mickey where are you from and how can I
help hi I'm from Tulsa Oklahoma and the
question that i actually had is has been
working on trying to figure out how to
start my makeup line um everything has
been sketched out but the only thing is
I don't know where it's actually to
start to know where to get the financial
health bars should I find an investor to
help me start Aventine ok how much one
is Jimmy everything that our research in
roughly around 50,000 feet and start
anywhere with the temples and everything
then the places that are researched in
California that makes makeup and what is
the money going to be used for the
sample for the people to actually start
making the samples in the product itself
or that holds the makeup inside
okay can you think of a way to bootstrap
this not go out and get money can you do
it without investing money into it oh if
I could make it myself I'm pretty sure
I'll be able to do that they meaning
that having all the products are
knowledge itself of how to even start
with the plastics in the thing to
actually that holds the makeup inside
now the makeup itself the eyeliner yeah
sure I can make them so can you start
with that as a product the makeup itself
no no just the eyeliner oh yeah so a big
thing with entrepreneurs recent money is
tough it's hard and it can be a
full-time job getting out there to get
capital for your business and right now
if you go out what's your personal
credit life you have a good personal
credit it's fair okay so nobody's going
to give you money without a personal
guarantee like a banker will not give
you money with a personal guarantee and
investor coming on is going to take a
huge chunk of your company so the
fastest way to get started is to
bootstrap it find something to you can
you can start with that you can make
yourself if you look at any of the most
successful makeup companies how they got
started it's usually the entrepreneur
them styles in their kitchen in their
base and putting something together and
eventually opposed up to be a huge
company okay so if you can get started
on the eyeliner and make it amazing
there's something like really unique
about your honor that's different than
everybody else yes it is very unique
actually definitely stand out above the
rest okay and I feel like everyone well
for what I feel like it woman has been
waiting on an eyeliner that actually
will not dirty up their purse as a woman
I mean walking around with a makeup bag
that you pull out your person that looks
like you're just a filthy person because
you know the make up Mel sorry there the
lid comes off inside your purse this is
definitely something that different
stands completely out everyone be
waiting for this and it has it's done
before and one this is great so you have
an opportunity here with one amazing
product that you can make yourself
without spending a ton of money on
that could launch your business yeah I
doesn't know that that that was my issue
literally this has been in the works for
10 years now this is a dream of mine
that I've been occasionally we got it we
got to start making this happen so don't
don't wait another 10 years before this
thing launches because you don't have
the money to do it start today start
simple start with that eyeliner get it
out fill it with it and then you can
explain to other products thank you
alright alright it's so important you
can just spend 10 years of your life
without chasing dream you got to take
action to something today to make that
thing go forward I believe it on dirt
and I want to see you grow a huge
company part of that is going to come
from recognizing and thanking the people
helped get you to where you are even if
you're just in start-up mode and haven't
gone far yet there's still people who
have helped you along your path friends
family colleagues who believe in you
would give you some support it's
important to thank them when was the
last time you reached out to anybody in
your network and just said thank you so
much for what you've done for me a key
component to success is gratitude and
knowing that you feel so grateful to the
people who've helped you get to where
you are let them know appreciate them
reach out to them I really got your
YouTube video now where I thank somebody
on my network some news helped me get to
where I am it's a personal video i post
on youtube so that others can share as
well but you'll have to do a video but
you have to reach out to people let them
know that you appreciate their help send
them an email take them out for coffee
or lunch pick up the phone and talk to
them send them a letter send them some
flowers something think about five
people who helped you get to where you
are today five people who impacted your
life and reach out to them to say thank
you it'll make you feel better it will
give you more positive energy that you
could pump into your business
it'll make them feel better and if you
show that gratitude and develop a habit
of gratitude people will want to keep
helping you out and you're going to need
help you cannot do this alone you will
need help to build the company that you
want to build so get into the practice
of thanking the people genuinely who
have helped you think of five people
today that you can reach out to get in
touch doesn't have to be expensive
doesn't have to take a lot of time with
some thought into it it'll change your
day and start to change your business
let's get to the call I have Michael on
the line Michael where are you from and
how can I help well I'm from Utah living
in New York getting ready to go back to
Utah all right what's what's the story
what's happening well I come from I'm
actually a singer and a professional
singer I should say and I one day I just
SAT and said hey what I'm going to do
when I start to get a vibrato like Bert
Lahr and somebody says hey you should
stop doing that and I really feel that
you know as vintage singers we have an
obligation to share what we've learned
and I feel that my voice teacher who
laid my foundation really knew what he
was talking about it was a very specific
and unique technique about voice
building as opposed to being a voice
teacher of voice coach about being able
to sing healthfully in its kind of a
simple explanation believe that you know
if you want a big body you do leave lift
weights and you do things like that his
exercises were designed to exercise the
muscles in the throat so that you didn't
strain and you didn't lose your voice
and so at 60 I think my voice sounds
better than it was when I was I thought
in my prime it when I was in my 20s very
cold analysis question well my question
is that I've gathered this group of
people that are kind of the fruit of the
this voice teachers tree and we're
trying to put together a kind of an
online
studio whereby students instead of
wasting that hour and half coming to us
that we are able to economically you
know go using paypal or or some other
means of paying for them to book one of
the singers within our our technique
group and then develop a kind of I call
it a singer silencer it's a device
that's that we're kind of working on to
allow you to rehearse in your apartment
and do these exercises without annoying
the neighbors are you going to do
coaching via Skype is that they do you
want to sell this wrong us yeah I
actually looked into my what inspired
this was that I saw that the university
of pittsburgh was doing online seminars
or on a specific type a type of vocal
techniques and i thought hey that could
be applied really to share this
technique and it's not really money
motivated although we all want to eat
but it's about sharing the art so what's
the problem right now i'm getting it
going well I we have kind of all the
elements and I'm kind of not we're kind
of it what do we do we got a website we
have do we copyright the idea do we you
know we're kind of at that stage where
it's kind of in get all the pieces of
their we're just not exactly sure where
to start with them oh yeah marking it
yeah how are we going to do that I mean
we have facebook and we have twitter
we're learning about how to manipulate
those we all have access to you know
groups of people and that would be you
know interested in you know in in doing
it to be able to reach a wider audience
but you know we're worrying of people
who you can partner up with just a
marketing partnership not part of your
business who have access to the students
that you're looking for well we kind of
have access to the students we don't
have the skill to actually put it into
effect how come in other words we we
hired somebody to kind of do a website
for us we're not really getting what we
need out of it and there it should be as
real simple thing but in my in my brain
you know there should be a who's
available you
the link you pay your whatever and then
you you they give you the code to call a
simple thing but it i do i need to
copyright this whole thing first or do I
not taught you know what I'm saying you
know God no you don't need the copyright
it you just got to get out there and
start getting some customers you don't
even need to build to a complicated
website the website could just be a
marketing brochure you can get this
started with type with Google+ and on
the homepage you just say you know
here's your paypal button here's the
whatever it is fifty bucks an hour right
and then you do we need to do do we need
a web page can't can it be done like
through Facebook and things like gin you
can you can't I mean it's more than
marketing I like so the technology
itself it's not super complicated how
are you getting in the message out and a
great way to do it is to partner up if
you have access to these students you
just have to let them know this thing
exists you have a simple page with your
message clear allows easier for people
understand right paypal button here if
you have the students that's that's the
hard part yeah we don't have the
technical skills to set that paypal
thing and all that up so what kind of
person would we want to partner up with
that would be able to do that kind of
stuff for us you could be a wary eye or
can you could do it through just paypal
itself you can set up a quick account
and it's not that difficult yeah I have
an account but I hate my mind the
linking of and all that stuff is where
we get into the complications yeah and
if you're going to make this big it does
help to have a web guy on board who
kinda knows what he's doing the remnants
of people who complement your weaknesses
it's not super difficult but it may be
worth second your network to see if you
have somebody who can do that component
for you but you're going to waste your
time yeah that dresser you're not we've
been doing and about you know we're all
afraid of you know talking about it
louder and having somebody steal the
thing out from under net undress start
with your network somebody has to have a
nephew and niece a grant a grandchild
somewhere to set this up for you it's
not a complicated to get started but
make sure you get darted and you bring
the people on board who can help you
okay okay the last house I enjoy second
idea I believe
in entrepreneurs and I want to see you
build company of your dreams to do that
you have to understand marketing I get
so many entrepreneurs to call them to
this show who write me on email who hit
me up on Twitter and social media and
they are at their wit's end you know
you've invested your life savings into
your business you think you have a great
product or service you're doing
everything you can working crazy hours
and for whatever reason things are just
not taking off and you're wondering how
can I market my business so people know
about me if I could fix my marketing I
could save my company most entrepreneurs
get their marketing wrong if you want
people to talk about you spread the word
then you need to give them a reason to
talk about you most businesses are
boring in the way they promote
themselves and so you're not going to
get amazing results by being born by
being average there are three main ways
to market a business level 1 this is
what most people do to say what they do
so if you're a landscaper you say I cut
grass i'ma landscape I cut grass boring
wrong nobody's going to pay attention
I've already forgotten your business you
have to stand for something more next
level up is instead of talking about the
features of what you sell the talking
about the benefit you provide so instead
of saying I cut grass I'm a landscaper
you talk about how you save people time
you offer convenient you make their
house look beautiful you make their
neighbor's jealous lose some benefits
that you're offering that's the next
step up and if you do that you'll have
some success you're much better off than
being in that first category but if you
really want to make progress on your
marketing the third level the one that
most people never get to the biggest
mistake that entrepreneurs may is
there's no feeling with their marketing
there's no feeling behind their company
marketing is about values people want to
know what you stand for that's what's
memorable you want to stand out you have
to stand for something and the first two
that we talked about our about making
people think this one is about making
people feel you have to create a feeling
around your business dick one word that
defines you as a person pick one word
that is so important to you forget about
your company for now click one word that
defines you let's say it's family the
family is everything to you you love
your family you do everything for your
family you are defined by your family
now bring them into your business how do
you bring family into a landscaping
company you do it by treating your
customers like family you let people
know that when they come and work with
your business they're going to be part
of your family unless what you believe
in you don't see you're going to go cut
somebody's garage your say you're going
to cut it like it was your own you're
going to cut their grass like it was
your lawn we're going to trim their
hedges like it was your mother's
property that makes people feel
important that gives them a feeling to
connect to instead of just saying I cut
grass so figure what that one word is
for you what does that make you special
what is it that you read that were to
get too excited yes that's what I
believe it and then use that in all of
your marketing make people feel before
you ask him to do something that's a
message is worth spreading that's what
kind of people will talk about and
that's how you take your marketing to
the next level I want to get to the
calls I have Joshua on the line Asha
what's going on where are you from and
how can I help hello I in from Millen
spinners Ohio farm country farm country
all right yeah and my question is how do
you move your stuff product idea forward
I did get that and this will jump but
what's your what's your business idea
well I like like isn't big block
something with the watch
um I'm not really sure how to go about
it i don't know if i have a prototype
drill or what are you trying to do make
watch it watch it okay i didn't i didn't
hear the proper you want to make your
own line of watches yes what's wrong
with the watches that are out there
right now I just don't feel like they
have enough designed as markers towards
younger people okay look through my fear
babe body referrals and rich people an
admiral ok so you want designed watches
for the everyday guy Brett all right
what's your background and watches have
you ever done anything with watches oh I
have now I just know I want to do
something business my grandparents on
the Mount of pop stores and I team the
fun they had they enjoyed it right now
I'm in college so well why watches over
something else I just like box go
surfing for walkers okay so that's good
so you want to start it around your
passion I just want to make sure that
watch it to something you love doing and
it's not just a why don't I do watches
right you're right there right like you
love watches your whole life every
thousand high schooler servers and gas
money than by the first black I do
certain stuff alright that's good that's
a good stuff have you ever done anything
in business before no okay like have you
work that your your parents mom and pop
shop right okay really my advice here is
to start getting a little bit more
experience in your field so it's great
to have this plan for a watch company
but if you don't know what you're doing
you've never done anything with watches
before besides being a collector then
you could dump serious cash into this
company and it fails on you right I
would try to go work for a watch company
that you look up to not not one of the
big ones but look for a smaller company
you can go get an internship from learn
from them you know learn the ropes get
some contacts get some experience so
that when you're ready to launch you
have a lot under your belt already
right um the thing is you know how
people say you know never use no money
insert business so how do you get a
investors destruction like a this is for
the word now you know lose our money
yeah it's critical you want to investor
the trust you you got to give them
something that they can believe in right
I know you're in the early stages now
that's okay that's cool that's where a
lot of the excitement is but if you want
to invest for now they're not going to
give you anything okay right like you
don't really know what you're doing yet
you have kind of a vision to design
washes for the everyday guy that's cool
but like you got no track record no
business experience so imagine somebody
comes to you and says hey give me money
to start this business but I've never
done anything before and you know I have
a concept but I'm not quite sure what
I'm going to do you're not going to give
them the money right right so the best
thing is you have to learn about this
business right oh now you're still
you're still in college you said yeah is
there a company that you could do an
internship with or work part time with
in the watch business or you can learn
from in my area of that shirt I was
check on that I don't think I have a
watch stuff in here okay anybody related
to watches it could be a watch retailer
anything related to watch this you can
start to learn the business right the
thing is you want to learn while still
getting paid right like if you start a
company now you take on money you're
going to you're going to probably lose
it all because you don't know what
you're doing yeah and that is you that's
fair for where you are right if you can
learn while still getting paid by
somebody else you make all your mistakes
on their dime then when you're ready to
launch you know more of what you're
doing if you go work for a watch
retailers there is no manufacturer in
your area but a retailer and you learn
how to sell watches that could be a huge
benefit to you when you go out and try
to sell your own product right and
another thing I hear people say you know
Asia a business degree really worth it
so switching gears a little bit there
you know what it's always good to have
something to fall back on you know there
are a lot of entrepreneurs
I've dropped out of college and had some
success with it but I personally believe
that there's still no value to it
there's good to have an education just
in case the entrepreneurship thing isn't
for you like you've never started your
business you don't know if this is going
to work out or not right right it
entrepreneurship is hard it's fun but
it's hard it's not for everybody right I
started my business part time when I was
in University and when I graduated
instead of going to get a job I
continued on with my business and I said
I give myself one year to do this and if
that doesn't work out then I go back and
take those job and I never went back to
get josh is it took off what I would
recommend staying in school finish your
degree start part-time learn about the
business stupid for you get some
experience make a little money while
working out of watch retailer learn the
ropes that when you're ready to launch
you have everything you need to be
successful okay well thank you sir sure
no problem Joshua good luck and for
everybody who's listening in the same
boat you're trying to launch your
business oh just launching is never done
anything before that's a recipe for
failure you're going to lose your money
you're going to lose your investment
money learn about the business
difference for you welcome back to the
oven Carmichael show I believe in
entrepreneurs want to see you be
successful and part of that is bringing
on a team you can't do everything
yourself if you want to be a huge
success you have to get people under you
and I know it's a huge problem for a lot
of entrepreneurs you finally decide to
grow you put out an ad you gotta promote
the odds you got a screen candidates you
have to interview people finally you
have somebody you think is a good fit
you bring them on board then you have to
train them for a couple months to train
them and then they leave or you fire
them because they're not going to work
out it's so frustrating and a lot of
entrepreneurs to say this is ridiculous
i'm not going to do that again that was
just a huge waste of my time I'm going
to do everything myself can't think like
that I know it's hard I know it's
frustrating but if you want to build
something huge you have to be able to
build beyond yourself now
teasing here if you want people to stay
and don't feel bad because a lot of
entrepreneurs you look at any successful
famous entrepreneur you look at who
their first employee was they're often
not so with the company companies chair
and employees at the beginning and the
main reason is because the people you
bring on don't have the same values as
you if I'm that landscaper who believes
in family and I need a website designer
I could hire a great website designer
with great web skills but if they don't
believe in family like I do then they're
not going to stick they're going to move
on to something else something that they
believe in and it's on you as an
entrepreneur to get clear on what you
stand for and communicate that message
the problem isn't the employees it's you
and your recruitment process you feel
what you feel you know what you feel but
you can't articulate it can't
communicate it you have to get clear on
what is your company stands for you use
it in your marketing but you also using
your recruitment you get people on board
who believe in what you're doing who
would love doing what they're doing it
your business so much that they would
volunteer to do it does they love your
direction they love your vision they
love what you stand for those are the
employees that you want it's not going
to happen to you get clear what your
values are at time for one more caller
I've got Emilio on the line Amelia where
are you from and how can I help I'm from
Hamden Connecticut all right welcome to
the program what's going on thank you
I'd said like a simple question I don't
want to get into too many details but um
I just turned 25 years old and I was
wondering if I wanted to I have very
great idea of starting my own business
but I know it's going to take a lot of
capital which I don't have right now
what is the first step into action from
taking that idea into putting into a
plan start talking to customers of that
start talking to people who can
potentially buy your product and getting
their feedback he do they like what
you're doing or not so I get investors
no not investors customers okay they're
talking to people who could potentially
buy what you're going to end up creating
you have a lot of customer interest then
you can go and get investors the
investors aren't the problem mm-hmm the
problem is when most people go to
investors they just
have an idea here's a great idea I think
it's going to work but they have no
traction like show me that this is going
to work hmm and that comes from talking
to customers and getting in to say i
love this i would spend money on this I
need to have this I used to be in the
venture capital business so I got
pitched tons of ideas and ninety-nine
percent of them got rejected mostly
because it was just an idea what are you
trying to sell me well I was I was over
waiting my whole life I lost about a
hundred pounds i turn 18 years old so I
feel my passion is to help other people
lose weight so I would like to open the
first ever like healthy fast food
restaurant chain of them okay and help
the world you know because I feel like
jovi series it's over a third of the
United States and if I could help them
lose weight by providing healthier food
at reasonable times it'd be you know
dream come true yeah that's a huge
problem you're dressing and it's awesome
that you've been through it yeah if you
look at any so here's some more homework
uses you're starting up model success
look at every fast-food chain restaurant
mean that that you can look up to their
model not good not to what they're
selling right like you don't agree with
what McDonald's of selling right yeah
but you can respect their business model
and how they built that up that's what
you want to do for healthy fast food so
look at all of these stories look at how
they got started look at how they went
from that idea to open up the first door
you know all of them bootstrapped it up
they didn't go and get huge investors
they started with one little location
even it could be like a side stand on
the road just something small to get
started and it became a phenomenon they
use smart marketing they had a great
message and your story is amazing thank
you that should be front and center yeah
but you don't have to think it's great
to have the big vision I don't want to
shut that down like you want to be
national this is this is a great vision
yeah you got you got to take the steps
to get there and there's involve step so
a lot of times entrepreneurs get so
caught up in the big picture that then
they take no action
and you're kind of stuck as to what do I
do next the next step is to get started
do something small yeah make your own
line make it from home start selling
them these people like it tweak your
recipe you're making a little bit of
money like show that people will be
willing to pay you or what you're
producing sure you don't have to open up
your own store to start you could start
by being you backing on another location
you know something that if you look at a
health store maybe you've gone to a
supplement store or any kind of healthy
related or that doesn't sell food you
could open up a stand there every
Saturday I sell your food do people like
it it's an era then when you go talk to
investors they're going to be more on
board because you have a little bit of
money coming in you can show the people
will want to buy your product yeah most
people who do this we go after
investment have nothing but an idea
until they get shut down like business
plan goes right in the garbage you have
to show that you have more momentum
behind your business but don't let it
don't let that fear hold you back like
don't make it seem like you have to have
that investment to start this business
if you research these stories and how
these guards got started McDonald's when
these are all of those guys they said it
from nothing they bootstrap that they
built it up themselves they tested their
product that eventually got an amazing
company had as a result yeah if you have
a great store I think it could go far
thank you now the next step is that
should do your homework and get working
I will thank you okay yep good luck
believe in singular for anybody also has
a symbolic have a business plan you have
an idea you want to get at lost one
investor show the hasta momentum go to
investors with something with some
customers who are paying you not a lot
of money but something show me some
momentum and don't let the fear of not
having enough money hold you back from
doing something otherwise you're going
to sit for 10 years never having built
anything and regretting what you've done
with your life to get to work
we're already at the end of the show
with crazy time really flies thank you
doctor joining me I had a lot of fun I
want to thank my producer Steven
Fernanda you guys are great I will be
back in a couple weeks look forward to
hearing about your businesses continue
to grow continue to believe thank you
guys I'll see you soon